Lord Varys has proven her loyal servant
proven himself loyal quite the opposite
if he dislikes one Manik he conspires to
crown the next one what kind of a
servant is that the kind of the realm
needs incompetent should not be rewarded
with blind loyalty as long as I have my
eyes I'll use them castrate a root and
stem as a young boy by a magician and
left on streets the divers clung on to
his lie by begging stealing and selling
what parts of his body still remained
before just forming himself into one of
the most influential figures in the
Seven Kingdoms where is the so called
spider a master of whisperers the
multiple Monarchs is one of the most
mysterious and most interesting game of
Thrones creations and one of a few truly
lowborn characters establish himself as
a main player in the HBO show in earlier
seasons it was often difficult to tell
what the end game of the ball you know
could turn out to be like Littlefinger
who boasts a similarly sharp set of
scheming skills he clearly had a
long-term agenda
unlike Littlefinger however who craves
power for himself first has repeatedly
claimed that he is working only for the
good of the realm and for the innocent
people who live in it he will lie and
betray his kings but it's all to make
sure that the right person sits on the
Iron Throne Littlefinger might crave
chaos Boveri Sultan may live on
stability challenged by Danny who
questioned his loyalty earlier in season
7 the eunuch launched a passionate
defense of himself when I was a child I
lived in alleys gutters abandoned houses
you wish to know where my loyalties lie
not with any king or queen but with the
people he told her the people who suffer
under despots and prosper under just
rule the people whose hearts you aim to
win if you demand blind allegiance I
respect your wishes
grey born can behead me or your dragons
can devour me in this respect versus one
of the most forward-thinking characters
in the game of Thrones world of late he
certainly seems to be favoring his
feelings towards the nearest
understandably caused by daily burning
people alive all rulers demand that
people bend the knee that's why their
rule is she gave Tolly a choice the man
who had taken up arms against her what
else could she do not burn him alive
alongside his son Daenerys is not her
father
and she never will be with the right
counsel
you need to find a way to make her
listen because of this many have
speculated that Varys could abandon and
betray Danny after all possibly even
aligning himself with the noble chants
no whose claim to the throne is the
strongest of all this could be very
severe so that you if you don't mind my
saying I don't think you should return
to Westeros I'm not sure you'd be safe
here I will return to you spider one
last time my lady I have to die in this
strange country
just like you and I swear this if you
ever betray me I'll burn you alive
anyway a year ago I introduced a theory
in which where's who's been called Lord
at the respect not because of obligation
as he is not a nobleman actually
highborn and everyone should call him
Lord I introduced with a few theories in
which verse is either the last member of
how star bag that is considered to be
extinguished by Lord Tywin Lannister or
is the last member of house Blackfyre
this is considered to be extinct by the
time the show takes place let's start
with the figure image Varys is the last
living member of house Blackfyre so far
the showrunners decided only to include
house Blackfyre among the noble houses
listed in the lineage and histories of
the Great Houses of the Seven Kingdoms a
book which Ned Stark read in the very
first season however this could change a
very shalese a Blackfyre one site
reduced about a few hints that some code
while some are considering as a proof of
heirs being a Blackfyre I'm going to
introduce a better possibility of Eris's
major betrayal over Daenerys Targaryen
what start with the fact that george RR
martin and showrunners have hinted a
versus someone of a royal descent as
only people with royal blood are being
used in magical rituals as a boy I
travelled with a troupe of actors
through the Free Cities one day in mere
a certain man made my master an offer
too tempting to refuse I feared the man
meant to use me as I'd heard some men
used small boys but what he wanted was
far worse he gave me a potion that made
me powerless to move or speak yet did
nothing to dull my senses with a hooked
blade he sliced me root
and stem chanting all the while he
burned my parts in a brazier the flames
turned blue and I heard a voice answer
his call
for all of you that are wondering if air
is being used in magical Rachel confirms
hers being of royal descent the answer
is yes the fact that the sorcerer took
his main parts into the fire resulted
with the voice speaking from the flames
confirms the statement it might be a
confirmation that various Kings bladder
blood that has tremendous power in magic
well this fact that I mentioned could be
considered as a probe there's also one
more than interesting fact and it's a
fact that sorcerer stanga's cut out we
can clearly see this in the fourth
episode of the third season a scene in
which first introduced Tyrion with a
sorcerer that tortured him in his youth
first probably carried out himself in
order to either keep his secret or him
being a Blackfyre or to keep the words
that were spoken from the flames and
raps this sounds even more interesting
when you take into consideration that in
the books verse does this talk his
little birds
it's very strongly implied that he makes
sure that the tongues of all child Spice
refers to as his little birds are
removed to ensure they will never be
able to give anything away
anyways the second hint of airs being
black fires in a fact that Ferris keeps
his head shaved verse might be doing
this to hide his hair color which
virtually is a black fire should be
platinum blond as it's one of the traits
passed on the black fires by the
Targaryen since the black fires are
infamous for their repeated and
unsuccessful attempts to overthrow the
Targaryen dynasty it was more than
enough for a huge amount of fans to
assume that Ferris will eventually
betray Daenerys another cool that my
going favorite to this theory which
wears is not loyal today needs in
Kumar's confrontation or Varys as we all
know Kim or accept a tyrants imitation
who sent it to gain her assistance in
convincing people to follow up Danny as
their protector rather than a conqueror
after King more except deterrence
imitation she met with Tyrion Lannister
inverse in the Great Pyramid of Meereen
welcome Erebus habitus says Tyrion
however she can as she believes the Dany
is the one who's promised first
interrupted their conversation he
pointed out in all Sanjay had proclaimed
Stannis Baratheon as the one who's
promised pointing out how accurate or
should I say inaccurate she was since
then he's had been defeated in the
battle black water first and later at
Winterfell as well but that time for
good
where's also stated their religions
overly self-assured of its own tenets
once again pointing out that no one
should believe in her words when another
red priestess was wrong after we're
stated all-out all that was in his mind
in that very moment as we could see in
mark confronted him
if not for your mutilation at the end of
a second-rate sorcerer you wouldn't be
here helping the Lord's Chosen bring his
light into the world knowledge has made
you powerful but there's still so much
you don't know do you remember what you
heard that night when the sorcerer
tossed your parts in the fire you heard
a voice call out from the flames do you
remember should I tell you what the
voice said should I tell you the name of
the one who spoke
we serve the same queen if you are her
true friend you have nothing to fear
from me Kim are approved and
demonstrated that she's not lying when
she says that she has some special
capabilities which she proved the true
knowledge about versus past especially
about the voice in the flames which may
very speechless
where's Dan already visibly shaken was a
spike in Mari he wants her to repeat for
him those same words or to identify the
speaker for him the word searchers
doesn't want to hear again because of
fear that it brings to him a hint that a
huge amount of fans are considering as a
proof of Aris not being loyal towards
Danny's income our statement that she
said where's this heard the same Queen
if you're her true friend you have
nothing to fear from me to conclude this
theory there's certainly a possibility
of errors being a Blackfyre and if he
truly is his betrayal over Danny is not
even questionable now that I introduced
with a theory in which verse is secretly
a Blackfyre let me now introduce refuge
versus the last living member of how
star back in this theory varus does not
hate the Targaryen Buddha Lannister's
how star back was a noble house from
Derby hole in the westerland's and is
considered to be extinguished by the
Tywin Lannister himself throughout the
history one of the Lords of Darby Hall
was killed while fighting for Prince
Aegon Targaryen during the battle
beneath the gods eye during the first
Blackfyre rebellion on the other hand
the Tarbox supported both sides who
should explain where's his loyalty
towards Targaryen in vases darbus became
close allies with house rain by joining
their house for marriage and thus cows
rain had ties with House Lannister of
Casterly Rock
the topic started using funds from Lord
Titus Lannister to rebuild crumbling
tower big hole the tower backs along
with house rain quickly became the most
powerful vessels of the Lannisters but
they were also very spiteful as the sons
of Lord Titus for growing up the witness
their father being mocked by the Tarbox
which was a huge mistake for the tower
backs and reigns his own of the Lord
Titus Sons was diamond Lancer diving
because of his own father who wasted
away a huge amount of their fortune
important vestments and hosts allowed
himself to be mocked at court became
ruthless this later made him the most
feared and respected Lannister that has
ever lived a stabbing grew up he started
Manning repayment for all gold that had
been lent out which eventually resulted
with rain Tarbuck rebellion against Lord
Titus Lannister this however a result of
the time his decision to personally put
down the rebellion Darby Hall was the
first to fill time in Zanger who
defeated and commanded beheading so Lord
Arabic and his followers extinguished
their house and established a fearsome
reputation of House Lannister as diamond
was finished with at our Beck Center
followers time
Leinster hosts against trains which
eventually result of a time is ruthless
destruction of house reyne the downfall
of reigns and time is ruthless is
immortalized in song the rains of
castamere which gave darker meaning to
the common phrase a Lannister always
pays his debts now that I introduced
with house Arabic and its destruction
here we come to a theory which Varys is
the last remaining member of hosts are
back which would mean that Lord Tywin
Lannister did not kill every single
member of the house in the books it's
mentioned that one member have Starbucks
arrived time in slaughter and was
smuggled across the Narrow Sea to Essos
where´s claims to be born across the
Narrow Sea in lys but it seems that he
deeply cares about Westeros unusual for
someone who wasn't born there as we all
know where's got his revenge over the
second-rate sorcerer that emasculated
him and perhaps a testifying against
Tyrion in court he also got his revenge
over demand a destroy his house Tywin
Lannister with Tyrion being found guilty
beside affected fairs managed to provide
his screen a precious and trustworthy
adviser a virtual is at our back he also
got his revenge over timing a
collaboration with Jaime the result of a
Tyrion being freed from prison also
resulted with Tyrion killing his father
meaning that first had a major role in
diamonds death having in mind that
versus the most forward-thinking
character is definitely not out of the
realm of possibilities that it was his
plan all along the less notable fact
that may go in favor to the steering
which versus the turbek is in a
conversation between him and Tyrion in
season 2 episode 9 let's take a look
I've always hated the bells they ring
for horror a dead King a city under
siege exactly as you can see a few
months before the Battle of Blackwater
we're still - Tyrion how much he hates
the bells could this hatred have its
origins in his early memory of his self
start by being under attack either way
one thing is clear George always
intended bears to be a complicated
difficult to read character in the show
his declaration of carefully qualified
support for Dany Mecca felt sincere but
versus still somebody that the Dragon
Queen and via the audience should be
watching closely
one thing regarding versus fate is
certain he will not survive the Game of
Thrones and he will die in Westeros
could it be that Dany will have her
dragons burned him alive as she promised
him she would if he ever betrays her